[Music]
in heads or tails news oh she likes a
video I like both do Bo
Jason tails and getting head submitted
by Jamal Ian chair thrower oh good this
one go throw it I'm tired that's why we
know we have a Jamal Yin chair thrower
because they throw the chair translator
yeah yeah like do you think that would
really make you feel better it's
sometimes Bart says he makes him feel
better no like it's someone else yeah
yeah yeah cuz you'll see him freak out
he's like yeah I feel the same way but I
felt good and then he's about to jump in
and then he stops cuz it's like a
cathartic yeah it would make me feel
better because I know that I'm rich
enough to have someone do that for me
yeah I think that's what porn is like if
you can't have sex but you watch other
people have sex you're like oh yeah good
job because you just you're [ __ ]
yourself to that yeah yeah but you're
pretty you know you're vicariously
getting it out well you know what I'm
not lying
thank God I'm behind this screen cuz one
of them probably smells and people are
nasty up close and none of them want to
be there yeah I can imagine orgy smell
like the inside of the McDonald's Oh God
like feet and slow people's skin like
mine no I know your skin smells good to
me but like other people like sweaty he
did the one at the combo okay [ __ ] girl
did a shower and then and then you
immediately go doggy style and that
booty hope is the first smell it's been
in the pants the whole day and as soon
as you open up that crease it goes and
you're just like [ __ ] no battle no
wonder people [ __ ] while they're drunk
but you know it's gonna go away
[Laughter]
through the mouth there's the English
you know what until it airs out there's
the initial you know we've been [ __ ]
friction dating you got a dog there its
moist all that [ __ ] is getting hot and
steamy you're sweating and then when you
pull down those [ __ ] panties it goes
it just eats your butthole like I do you
don't you shower every single time see
that says to you I will never [ __ ]
look that will be so [ __ ] up if I take
a dump
if I take a dump and let her [ __ ] eat
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up but there are people
in this world that will do that and they
like the mask but not me
i'm hygena he makes comments like that
and then yes frustrated what I don't let
him just go to town whenever he wants
I'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
because you're not taking in the whole
message the whole message is your balls
nasty as [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
you only take the first part of it the
whole message is don't be self-conscious
don't be self-conscious cuz we don't
give a [ __ ] it happens but we look past
that [ __ ] cuz that's how party we are
the last time I ate yard you had a
period you you can literally have a
stomach flu you could be puking [ __ ]
and guys will be like well you know what
you take a shower we're still [ __ ]
yeah you could be on the toilet oh yeah
you put me in the middle of writing and
then you're like hold up I gotta take a
[ __ ] you go to the bathroom you come
back the [ __ ] [ __ ] fills the room air
don't [ __ ] matter we're finishing
that's that's all guys wrong and that's
the beauty of Jake he needs you click on
this video trying to see because she
hasn't even read the headline no you get
all of it so here we go right here I'm
never introducing a boyfriend to you
guys ever
why if I ever got a boyfriend I'm never
bringing him to JK because all the [ __ ]
you guys talk Oh God accept it yeah he
already knows all this stuff he's gonna
butthole talk by the way you're welcome
for that you're welcome just just close
the video
it's officers have been placed on leave
after using a coin toss to determine the
outcome of an arrest what this is boring
it's true see that's all you guys have
to share this video just tell them like
watch the beginning of yes story /
butthole story this the last five
minutes is it's like it this is how you
know you should never take JK seriously
exactly if for some reason says well
Jake he's a bit of a [ __ ] here's 5 mins
I'm talking on but hold the [ __ ] not
minding it
I appreciate that I'm taken seriously
okay so this story takes place in
Georgia body cam footage revealed that
these officers decided what to do with
this woman who they pulled over for
speeding whether to let her go or to
arrest her and they pulled out this coin
flipping app and didn't even have a coin
and no one has coins anymore oh my god I
have ten cents right here yeah it's not
in your wallet point proven
no tail thrust all right so it was
arrest his head tails is released so she
would have been released in your
acquaintance
all right so I'm gonna show you guys
this body kid when she caught for
speeding why would she get arrested
yeah was she's speeding a lot she could
have been going over the limit where
they can arrest
I think it's or something so they were
speeding I mean she was speeding but
because the road conditions were wet
they arrested her for speeding and
reckless driving that was a reason I see
so because I know when my friends raced
they got there they got arrested and got
their cars impounded for going 100
something on a 55 yeah was it over 20
miles over this man is this reckless
they had their cars impounded and they
didn't learn their lesson they were
still trying to be fast and furious it's
in the Asian blood man Tokyo Drift yeah
I know yeah all right mom's Honda Civic
know when you drop that song in an Asian
nightclub everyone loses their [ __ ] even
now do you go to Tokyo hmm that one the
teriyaki boys I like that song Sammy
makes me feel so this woman Sarah is 24
years old she was running late for work
so she sped past the patrol car and
apparently she was going over 80 miles
an hour that's why people shouldn't work
you go
you have a job you have to have you have
a commitment you have to crush police's
man man just quit quit here's the video
you wouldn't have to pay for a car if
you did have to work on her freedom do
me a favor I thought they were gonna
Sarah Webb was arrested and taken to
jail on the flip of a coin wow these
people really put my didn't know about
it being interviewed let's discuss not
the Queen blowing yeah
ha dump is hard for me to bump get
caught she said I have no certain videos
and I'm absolutely refused your
prosecutor's case I wanted chicken so
she she refuses to prosecute the case
judge refused to prosecute the case
because after she reviewed the body cam
footage that's
stupid sound like a couple of sorority
yeah right like Dawson
that's how indecisive girls are like
together they can't even decide it's
like what do you want to eat what do you
want to eat and then let's flip a coin
that's a restaurant no that's good yeah
that's pretty hardcore though I haven't
seen anyone really get arrested like
yeah for just speeding to work if they
were like racing in the cops knew or
like if they were drunk driving that
that happens I wonder if she can see
this [ __ ] out of them and get like
millions cuz of that if she didn't get
prosecuted so maybe mm-hmm
that's emotional distress where you're
just speeding and if it's like only ten
miles like and you go to jail
yeah it's like [ __ ] I wish I could sue
life sometimes for emotional distress
cuz sometimes I'm just emotional and
nothing happy and Bush you see my
parents was I didn't ask for this yeah I
don't have to be here to my parents I
just guilt them and then it makes me
feel good and then I get sad cuz they're
like it's like if they get sad I can't
get at first I'm like yeah that's right
[ __ ] you're mean and then later what
did I do
it felt good for just a second damnit
that's so real cuz you know you got that
resentment and you're like yeah but you
to let me do what I wanted to I had
dreams mom and she's like I know but I
was busy providing for you and I'm like
[ __ ] you need to address some [ __ ] I
know I know
no no yeah yeah I do okay they're super
young are they getting [ __ ] fired and
[ __ ] so they have been placed on
administrative leave press when was the
one that suggested the coin flip these
girls are dumb as [ __ ] they're doing an
internal investigation right now
what if she was fat what if she was
trained to do that it's like when you
don't know when you don't know consult
the coin what if they have like a
[ __ ] eight-ball should I take her to
jail I remember the old school [ __ ]
the one that you open I don't know girl
what do you think let's consult the
board is it gold ports or something but
they have like a carbon fiber police
[ __ ] graded one yeah it's like brick
one two three four like the code of the
way you have to write the ticket for
yeah don't you start with like how many
letters is on their name you go up door
what's your cup yeah
[Music]
[Music]